Are you lost?
Huh? So, you're waiting for someone?
Who are you waiting for?
Can't you talk?
Then why don't you say anything?
I'm... I'm not supposed to talk to...
I know, "Don't talk to strangers," right?
You're very grown-up because
you're careful. You can talk now.
You should hear my story.
My father and mother
and grandma and brother all got lost.
Did you lose someone?
My mommy.
Your mommy?
My mommy went away.
I know. There've been
a lot of missing parents lately.
But it's only your mom, you'll find her.
Excuse me, this is Toshio Kimura.
Can you please call his mom?
Oh, he's lost?
No, he's not, they were separated.
Right.
And your first name, Mr. Kimura?
-Toshio.
Toshio, then.
Wait here a minute, OK?
And you? Are you his sister?
No, no relation.
My whole family's lost.